castillo right now he's almost done
hittable or at least he has been
keep ryan hayes a handful of games up in
the three spot of the order and tonight
bats
second hard hit again
you just you can't wait for each one of
his bats sally sets up outside
could be too double play
well done from not that far away about
an hour's drive
to the north new carlisle ohio for
j.t brubacher he'll get the nod for the
bucks and the batter's nick castellanos
broken bat floater going to be a tough
play
[Applause]
just in time i thought they got him but
castillons per usual busting it down the
line
[Music]
backhand played newman there's one and
hayes to first and a wide throw and bell
comes off the back
the nine batters the catcher john ryan
murphy
and even looking inside didn't help him
third strikeout for castillo 0-2
good night irene i mean see you later
three up three down first
and a swing and
a miss down on strikes key brian hayes
he has fanned the last three batters
he's faced
two strikeouts in the inning felice
castillo has closed out each of the last
three innings with punch-outs he has
six on the night it'll be voda winker
and mustache three four and five against
jt brubanker brubaker has walked one
he's giving up one infield hit that's it
three two pitch swinging him in struck
him out
jesse winker struck out his first time
here's the o2
swinging a miss struck him out at the
top of the zone with a fastball
brubacher with back-to-back strikeouts
in the inning three in a row
gotta like it being aggressive um
going upstairs on that particular pitch
newman with a base hit his first time
around
newman goes down on strikes back to back
strikeouts for luis castillo and
seven overall
i mean he's getting used to pitching out
of that full wind-up isn't he
sure is blistered backhanded by jose
garcia
pretty play what a play garcia on that
ball that was scalded up the middle by
gregory polanco
and that's a guy that just can't buy a
hit
jose garcia bats
this will fall garcia for the two on
base hit
gasali bats with garcia at first and the
3-2 again here comes
a floater garcia rounding second base on
his way to
third back-to-back hits for the reds
here in the fifth
maybe yakiyama is up to the challenge
into left field that's a base hit this
will score one they're going to hold up
casalli
and akiyama's caught between first and
second base casalli coming to the plate
throw to the plate
and he will be in a rundown he's a dead
duck
the pirates execute but the reds do get
a run
an rbi hit by akiyama
garcia scores easily casalli held up but
akiyama
was on his way to second base and paid
the price
castianos is singled today and struck
out
him out of the game into the gap he's on
his way to second base
head first slide it's a lead off double
for the reds
all right sam howard into the game and
the reds are going to counter with a
righty tyler stevenson
3-2 coming fastball right on the inner
edge he struck him out
here's mike bustakas bounced
right side and on to first
sam howard gets the job done and that'll
bring eric gonzalez to the plate who has
struck out in both of his advanced
swing and a miss nine of them for
castillo
revolves two strikes two outs
they'll be on the move
[Applause]
struck him out tenth strikeout for
castillo
seven innings of shutout baseball
and the batter is colin moran swaying
adamus he struck him
out and the reds win their fifth
straight